do you feel like uh things could have
been different had like Eminem maybe
being the biggest rap artist ever
embraced more of the Detroit scene
because it feels like he never really
embraced
the new move movement out of Detroit I
mean even the last like 10 even like
when Doughboy cash out was like oh CTE
it just kind of felt like there was like
Eminem was just over here on an island
and then there's this like Street that's
like bubbling in the scene and I really
never felt like he has embraced probably
didn't like he probably really wasn't he
remembered a different type of artists I
feel like when you that type of man it's
Eminem I feel like he probably don't
even listen like he probably wasn't
listening right like to that type of she
probably would just focused on him he
probably had his own people somebody was
an artist yeah because I'm the type of
I'm that I'm like that I don't really
like it right like sometimes you don't
even listen to like you hear me you're
just getting them zones where it's been
times where I didn't listen to nobody
but my people I listen to everybody now
and plus I feel like Royce has done a
good job of like embracing some of the
young yeah hell yeah so he probably
liked the boys put him and Eminem can't
relieve him but I feel like Eminem I
mean Eminem he I got a song I'm on the
future with Eminem son like I can't I
got no bad nothing it is
you hear me so how many artists were on
that rep
[Music]
down to about eight yeah it's funny
because I forget who I was talking to
but they were like man I didn't know I
was gonna how are you gonna say but it's
like I think a couple of people on that
song didn't know they were gonna be on a
song with the other person man how crazy
was that like did you like were you
nervous getting on Detroit too and like
doing that record like did you kind of
understand the concept of it like I
didn't know what it was gonna do I was
really hell no I wasn't nervous I was
just we read a lot of songs in that we
did a lot of songs we man we was working
for days because I was in there with us
like we was in there working but what
was that so like like explain what you
mean was it like a studio session with
Sean yep all of us was there like
everybody a lot of Detroit rappers were
there even that didn't make the song
everybody was there and then we did more
immunity but they just and then somebody
wouldn't even hit me like they just they
just they just laughed like they just
was picking different beats and putting
different versions that one they was
putting that [__] together tonight they
put it together nice though
when your mom finds out you're on a song
with Eminem is she excited hell yeah she
like yo what the [__] son my mama my
mama one of them people that you know I
feel like she won't even I'm just her
son her she don't even know like she
late to realizing who our son but
everybody knows Eminem yeah yeah it's
like it's like this is Eight Mile really
yeah yeah my mama yeah yeah everybody
calling me everybody hitting me you're
like what the [__] yeah yeah I love Big
Sean man Sean's one of the most genuine
guys in the game man yeah for sure you
guys got unreleased [__] together we got
a uh no we ain't got no relationship we
need to get in that [__] though yeah we
did a couple [__] there but I don't
really remember a lot of them songs yeah
like yeah for sure do you uh you've been
embraced by the West Coast in a
heavyweight La yeah you know you you got
[__] with you I think blue but is blue
books on your album yeah yeah yeah you
obviously got you worked with oh Jeezy
um kind of blue face [__] with you
what is it about I because I do feel
like there is like a connection between
specifically the bay the bay in Detroit
really got like a [__] thing going on
they're like it's like a bromance going
on you know what I'm saying but like how
did you end up like really kind of
locking in with LA and having La embrace
you the way they have [__] forever I
just like I'm a [__] that just like
when I say talent I just I don't know if
a [__] ain't gonna have no like [__]
ain't gonna be nobody ain't gonna know
if I like the music I'm banging actually
I'm writing you I'm tapping in I'm doing
this home with you my song you hear me
and I'm putting that [__] on my I just
wanna if I see China [__] bro I'm [__]
with this music let's just put this [__]
for yeah feel me that's what this [__]
have fun and help [__] and
other cities I didn't even notice that
[__] looked at me like they're
here and chill out y'all really [__]
out here they they [__] with you hard
out there they thought I was from here
[__] told me like yeah we we
thought you we was wondering like why we
never seen you like we ain't never seen
you in school or nothing we thought you
was from her you act just like us yeah I
never noticed that but hey I guess I
[__] with I [__] with like the Kelly
said hard they got the hardest rapper
right who was the first uh like couple
artists you really like locked in with
out here in a bay or L.A well either
give me like a couple for me first
[__] was yada uh SOB
um a little yes
uh let me think man you know his brother
Ralphie I thought I [__] with blue blood
yeah man there's so many [__] in L.A
bro I don't even know where like I
thought I [__] with the hell saying like
literally like yeah Draco obviously was
somebody else who I feel like uh has
like a lot of influence over a lot of
people that he doesn't get credit for
the rest of the piece to Draco what'd
y'all how long ago did you link up with
him before you got locked up with him
you never met him no no I met him like
we used to always pay time and talk like
from years but I never seen them in
person like never super tapped it with
Detroit yeah
so he's gonna be on your new album
that's big man yeah yeah how so that how
old is that record
[__] that [__] was like
man how long ago he passed like what was
that two years ago that [__] time he
passed December remember two years it's
been about a year that [__] probably
like three years ago like the tape like
that [__] for like three years ago then
yeah he was in the studio I remember
like because he did a couple freestyles
on my show and one day he just was just
playing hella shitty out with Detroit he
was playing all kinds of [__] with him
and Peezy and like he was super super
like dialed into what y'all were doing
out there it was a workaholic then he
used to be working and that [__] send
me some [__] yeah yeah that [__] crazy